I eat or Reiki is the proprietor and
head chef of Elcano he's paying his
daily visit to the port of Italia a
small town in the Basque Country on
Spain's Atlantic coast this is where he
always gets the fish for his restaurant
the menu depends on the catch of the day
I eat or has a chat with the fisherman
getting on with them is key it's the
most important thing because if I don't
know who fish and where the fish is so
difficult to know that the fish eats
okay and if they are fair they know us
and we know him in generation is we know
how we are and we know with what we work
I eat all reggae took over the
restaurant in the town centre from his
father turbot is among the house
specialities but there are other fish on
the menu too the fishermen set the price
there's no haggling this ensures that
the chef gets the best quality and there
are many ways of determining this you
know what the fish eat because they what
they eat they are to be near when they
are so efficient near is to is the is to
be fresh and the concept of decision of
the fishes all the year is not the same
if they are before making babies after
making babies grilled fish is a typical
Basque speciality the coals have to burn
for at least 2 hours before they are
ready
the most important thing is the concept
of the another fish and then it's one
way to how to cook the charcoal is a so
clean charcoal and they grilled but the
concept is not in the game the gossip
isn't efficient before it goes on the
grill it's important to salts the turbot
on both sides
I eat or Iggy has dressed up to do the
barbecuing his shirt is spotless but not
the basket for grilling the fish
there is a good reason that if we clean
the skin brogues and then the fire is in
the meat and estrella and it's so
important for us that you that the
turbot grills increase the skins
Edgard alerts is a concoction of vinegar
oil and salt it's served with the fish
to make sure the fish reaches the right
temperature experience is crucial it
should be ready after 12 minutes but I
eat or doesn't need a timer you look and
it's like the the fish is speaking to
you I am ready I am ready this is like
that you see here come here
you see pop pop pop you see like a
Balkan is because it's good it this is
the gelatin that want to take out
afterwards the fish bones have to be
removed
I eat raw Eric his father learned how to
do this by watching the local fishermen
before it is served a little more
awkward alerts is needed at the Econo
the turbot gets served on its own
without potatoes or vegetables there's
enough for three people the chef serves
the best bits in person the taste
differs depending which part of the fish
the flesh comes from but whether it's
from the dark top or the lighter path
underneath springtime is the best season
to enjoy grilled turbot